انا حكيت ايه فاطمه يلتقي المنتخب
البرازيلي مع المنتخب الكاميروني في استاد
لوسيل اليوم في الجوله الثالثه والاخيره
من دور المجموعات لبطوله كاس العالم قطر
2022 وسيخوض منتخب البرازيل المباراه وهو
على قمه المجموعه السابعه همم طبعا هاي
تعدل العلامه الكامله ومعه بطاقه العبور
لدوري 16 ومنذ صباح يوم امس ارتفع عدد
المشجعين في شوارع الدوحه وهو وهم طبعا
يرتدون الوان المنتخب البرازيلي الاصفر
والاخضر الشهير يعني اتحطت همم في مطار
حمد هنا حمد الدولي في قطر سبع طائرات
ضخمه قادمه من البرازيل تحمل المشجعين
منتخب كما حضر عدد غفير من البرازيليين
المقيمين في دول الخليج والبلدان العربيه
لحضور المباراه والتشجيع منتخب اكيد اما
مشجعين منتخب الكاميرون فهم طبعا مستعدون
لتسجيع منتخب بلادهم الذي يشارك للمره
الثامنه في تاريخه في منافسات كاس العالم
الكثير منهم وصل الى الدوحه والايام قليله
مع انطلاق بدايه او صفاره المونديال طبعا
جانبين معهم الاجواء الافريقيه الساحره
همم بالوانها المميزه وهازيج وهذه
المختلفه هذه تتحول معهم شوارع قطر اذا
اخذنا الصوره وملاعبها الى كرنفال مليء
بالمرح ومتعه همم كره القدم والروح
الرياضيه الايجابيه يعني اشتفنا كثير
اشياء تحصل هنا شوفي هنا عندنا المغرب
يعني بعدهم الشباب بيحتفلوا بفوز المغرب
امبارح وفي كثير يعني هلا شفنا كثير من
البرازيل موجودين هون موجودين موجودين
مشجعين البرازيل انا على فكره اخترتهم هيك
بالصدفه انتم من اي بلد اسباني
البرازيل براسين
كاميروني 3 0 وهذا المشجعين طبعا
البرازيليين انت تعرفين همم فاطمه انهم
دائما هيك دمهم حامل بتكون
احتفالات هنا في سوق واقف حتى حواري همم
الساعه 10:00 بتوقيت الدوحه